[Music]
have you ever heard of dragonflies that
snipe their prey with bolts of energy or
octopuses that serve as guard dogs or
necromancer bees that live in reanimated
carcass hives these images aren't pulled
from some bizarre medieval manuscript
nor are they long-lost renaissance
paintings
these are from the codex and versus a
modern world-building project from the
imagination of the brilliant artist and
writer luca vanzela brought to life
through collages of classical art the
world of codex and vs is full of flora
and fauna that have evolved to use
magical energy visitors from parallel
dimensions and fractures in space and
time at a glance the surreal scrambled
visuals are difficult to make sense of
yet like a medieval bestiary the project
does follow a unique system of internal
logic
so for this entry into the archive i'll
investigate the creatures people and
locations of this scrambled world and
reveal the hidden order to the chaos of
codex and vs
the land of codex inversus exists in the
wake of a cosmic upheaval known as the
collapse where extra-dimensional realms
crashed into the material world
releasing vast magical energies that
altered reality
understanding the realm as it exists
today is no easy task for the world is
full of strange oddities
yet we must start somewhere in the
center of the northernmost continent
lies the valley of delights a relatively
safe and idyllic region where magic
practitioners create surreal sights but
it's not just people casting the magic
in codex and vs even small creatures
like the bizarre transmuter snail have
evolved to use simple spells
in their neutral form a transmuter snail
is indistinguishable from an ordinary
snail yet if say a plant is out of reach
a transmuter snail will move their eye
stalks in specific patterns to rapidly
change their body gaining frog like legs
for jumping if trying to cross a puddle
a transmuter snail might adopt a
swimming form gaining a tail similar to
a tadpole's and when trying to carry an
object these snails might even gain a
long prehensile appendage equivalent to
an octopus tentacle
the first human spellcasters called the
evokers learned how to wield magic by
studying animals like the transmuter
snail these early wizards found that
existence can be shifted with the right
pattern and that pulling on the threads
of reality can be dangerous for spells
in codex and versus are strange and
unpredictable often altering the user's
physical body beyond recognition and in
the valley of delight some spellcasters
have also begun altering the biology of
animals the chimera cat is the result of
artificial speciation through
transmutation magic with a spring-like
body and piercing tail chimer cats are
designed to be the ultimate form of pest
control
for while the valley is an idyllic
locale it has a bit of a rat problem
manticorats are winged rodents that
never evolved to cast spells themselves
but are quite adept at sniffing out
magical ingredients on which to feed and
while the chimera cats proved effective
at catching the manticorats now the
valley is overrun with chimera cats
instead
in codex and vs human attempts to
rewrite existence often end with
disaster yet following the collapse of
other realms into the material world
humans now share territory with wiser
formerly mythic beings
north of the valley of delights the
long-lived elves build their eternal
kingdoms elves possess a greater
understanding of how to safely cast
spells than humans and specialize in
controlling the elements
in the mountains of the south
subterranean dwarves are more practical
in their reality manipulation creating
artificial beings to aid in their mining
and there's another tunneling life form
native to the southern continent
abduring termites are capable of
incredible feats of engineering they
have evolved to cast spells not with
their bodies but with the shape of their
tunnels through the digging of complex
patterns abjuring termite nests are
protected by a low level spell and are
virtually indestructible termite farms
have become novelty items with some
individuals putting them on display and
asking guests to try and smash them
which is physically impossible
yet the termites still have predators
the mudpecker is a bird that uses
stealth to catch termites inserting
their thin beaks into the nest's pores
without causing immediate alarm and
slurping clean one or two tunnels before
the defenses are alerted it's a strategy
similar to ordinary woodpeckers and
suggests that sometimes the best path is
the one of least resistance
in the southernmost region of the world
perhaps the strangest life forms of all
are the matras
sentient constructs of unknown origin
these clockwork beings strive to replace
chaotic biological life with precise and
reliable artificial creatures most
notably the mantras oversee the enigma
library a collection of texts no one is
able to translate the artificial
cube-headed curators of this library
search for a grand diagram a complete
and comprehensive explanation of how the
claps warped creation so far they have
found nothing
the primordial chaos of the collapse has
changed some populations in incredible
ways the seafaring halflings possess
bodies that defy perspective like living
optical illusions they seem to have
pieces missing from certain angles these
unsettling gaps which are common on
hands and arms cause no pain and are the
result of parts of their bodies phasing
through dimensional reality
and as is often the case in codex and
versus certain animals have evolved to
take advantage of similar magical
phenomena conjuring ants are tiny
insects with an impressive secret
like ordinary ants conjuring ant society
is mainly preoccupied with transporting
food back to the nest for later
consumption
but conjuring ants have found a faster
method than carrying the food themselves
by moving in a specific pattern around a
piece of vegetation conjuring ants can
fold space-time and teleport food
directly back to the nest
to the north reality becomes even
further warped here a marine paradise
co-exists with a prairie
known as the ethereal ocean this
environment is possible due to
out-of-phase water in the sky that
various fish swim through all animals
here can interact with each other even
if they respond to different
environmental conditions small fishes
graze the fur of horses sharks hunt
flocks of birds and spiders weave webs
to catch flying shrimp
in this vast region where the sky
behaves like the sea certain groups of
wizards have domesticated octopuses
which fill a similar role to dogs or
cats
some breeds of octopuses are able to
hunt for vermin and scare off intruders
while others are clever enough to fetch
tools and alchemical ingredients some
magi octopuses can even cast small
spells although they are too shy to do
so in public
the ethereal ocean is part of a kingdom
called the angelic unison ruled by the
ethereal descendants of celestial beings
the land is a place where anything can
happen
a realm of infinite wonders at the heart
of the angelic unison are grassy plains
populated by cosmic animals stargazing
cows are inherently magical creatures
that produce milk with calming and
relaxing properties the restless
insomniac sheep are the cow's opposite
with their milk acting as a natural
stimulant making sheep's butter a
popular breakfast food across the
kingdom
yet the most important animals in the
angelic unison are the holy cows
descendants of extra-dimensional animals
from before the claps that interbred
with their earthly counterparts holy
cows possess the ability to quell
aggression just by looking at someone
their halo horn signifies their
importance and their milk always tastes
sweet even when spoiled which can
actually be problematic and can cause
sickness if one isn't careful
the angelic unison is a kingdom where
almost all things possess some level of
extra dimensional distortion even stones
take on fantastical properties in the
floating plains a region famed for its
slabs of levitating rock while an
interesting novelty these boulders can
also be something of a nuisance
disrupting herds and keeping rain from
watering crops
on the western edge of the continent the
independent nation of beasts has formed
here many groups of humanoids with
animal features gather together under
one banner and cast unique spells
in crowded cities the cat folk are
common sight filling the knights with
the sounds of their serenades
unfortunately for the general populace
to be a good singer or just in tune is
not a prerequisite catfolk are also
excellent weavers and spellcasters
animal folk in general have a unique
attitude towards magic seeing the
energies of the dimensional field is
conscious and spells a way of asking the
field for assistance rather than
controlling it
snake folk are another common resident
in cities preferring to stay indoors due
to their cold-blooded physiology their
ancestral fangs make chewing difficult
and so they have a unique culinary
tradition based around soft foods snake
folk cuisine has become famous across
the continent and many serpents now run
popular taverns
shambling in the back alleys of beast
cities are unnerving pests the bodies of
deceased animals have been spotted
moving seemingly of their own accord
surrounded by buzzing insects these
corpses are in fact the mobile hives of
necromancer bees these bizarre insects
have come up with an ingenious way of
scaring off predators by hijacking the
expired bodies of animals larger than
they are necromancer bees reanimate
animals using rather complicated spells
for such tiny insects moving in
different formations called dances to
get the muscles of their hives working
once more strange as this might sound
ordinary bees can actually perform
complicated dances to communicate the
direction and distance of flowers to
their fellow hive members
deeper within the nation of beasts is a
bleak landscape dominated by cubes of
rock that look like they fell from the
skies
known as the hades badlands the region
is a land of oblivion where reality
unravels due to the cube's strange
properties those who pass through may
lose their memory their minds or their
physical form
even deeper within the beast nation the
secretive ravenfolk keep watch over the
ghost forest while they interact and
trade with the other nations they do not
permit anyone to enter their mysterious
domain
for while the ghost forest might appear
like an ordinary grove the fog works as
a pocket dimension which some plants and
animals have evolved to phase in and out
of
one such plant is the starberry which
produces an enticing fruit it wants to
be eaten but not by ghost animals since
they can phase out the seeds during
digestion to prevent this the fruit
possesses a cage of thorns that stings
only ghosts with mortals able to pass
through it unharmed eating a starberry
means putting the bramble into your
mouth which can be unsettling even if
you know it won't sting
the haunting ghost lilies are perhaps
the most important plants of the ghost
forest these mind-altering flowers
invoke memories in a sense of nostalgia
when smelled or ingested this property
has made the lilies a luxury good and a
common export to more distant parts of
the realm
in the margins of the codex and versus
world one of the rarer and more
destructive creatures are the evoker
dragonflies these insects are
carnivorous and they hunt like
sharpshooters waiting for their prey and
then striking from afar with impressive
spells summoned from their tails to
resist the recoil of the bolt evoker
dragonflies must use their claws to grab
on to whatever they are standing on
the kickback of their dart is also used
proactively as propulsion by the
dragonflies with the insects shooting a
bolt in the opposite direction they are
headed propelling them at high speeds
towards their destination
and destructive magic isn't limited to
insects ancient scriptures say that
beings known as the fairies once
wandered the world spreading ruin for no
reason other than their own amusement
the even grimmer counterparts of the
fairies the nightmares also tormented
the land and drew the ire of the angelic
unison
the angelic beings used the last spark
of their divinity to banish them to the
two moons that orbit the planet since
other dimensions no longer existed after
the collapse the nightmares were sent to
the onyx moon where scripture says they
remain to this day ravenous and waiting
for a chance to take their revenge
the fairies were banished to the jade
moon and faded into myth over the
passing centuries yet recently sightings
of eerie creatures wearing domes of jade
on their heads have begun and strange
lights appear in the sky when the moons
are full
across the world of codex and versus
perhaps no location is as fabled or as
feared as the elsewhere woods a piece of
crumpled space where reality folds like
paper the elsewhere woods are a place
where lost things go some say towers of
slithering flesh with geometric summits
rise among the trees their origin and
function unknown others claim the woods
are made of many different trees from
all over the world with patches of pine
forest and stripes of tropical jungles
and brambles from arid lands fading into
wet fields of reeds floating among these
branches are white cloud possums
inquisitive marsupials that hover as if
they weigh nothing at all some reports
claim fearsome al griffins prowl the
elsewhere woods defending their
territory with fierce attentiveness what
truth there is in such fables is
difficult to say for few return from the
elsewhere woods with their lives
one of the few well-documented beings of
the elsewhere woods is the illusionist
butterfly also spotted in other parts of
the world these insects have an
impressive form of camouflage from their
caterpillar stage illusionist
butterflies are able to change color to
match their surrounding environment with
uncanny precision following
metamorphosis however they hide in a
different way the venations on their
wings form a pattern capable of casting
an illusion spell
many real butterflies have spots on
their wings that essentially serve the
same purpose mimicking the eyes of
predators to scare off would-be
attackers yet the illusionist butterfly
takes this a step further with their
patterns capable of creating an illusory
owl that moves and flies next to its
creator these owl projections are rarely
complete with their bodies appearing and
disappearing in a waving shape still
it's an incredible form of camouflage
that shows when in the elsewhere woods
things are seldom what they appear
entering the elsewhere woods is no easy
task for the region cannot be accessed
through mortal means there are rumors
that the skulls of cyclopses giant
beings who went extinct long ago
act as natural portals into the
elsewhere woods
monsters of unknown origin stalk the
caverns where these skulls can be found
chimeras made from many different beings
reports describe creatures with tentacle
arms necks which split into fanged
mouths and disturbing heads shaped like
crying children yet where could such
nightmares have come from
some have theorized that the cyclops
skulls connect to other places with
spatial anomalies there are rumors of a
land beyond the ocean far from any known
land mass lit by a fracture in space
known as the second horizon no one from
the known world has reached the shores
of this land although many have tried
according to legend the land is
populated with three-eyed people a
lineage different from any other their
land is also populated with hammer goals
seagulls with the heads of hammerhead
sharks what truth is there to such
strange tales no one can say for certain
for in the margins of codex and versus
there will always be things which evade
all understanding
observing the world of codex and versus
is like looking through a fractured
window with the images shifting and
merging before your eyes yet this
scrambled world of fables and myth
follows its own kind of rules if one
looks closely enough there are countless
other strange and wondrous aspects of
codex and vs i wasn't able to cover here
and you can see more of the art and read
more of the narrative using the links in
the description and if you find this
world as interesting as i do i encourage
you to follow and support luca vanzella
who is continuing to flesh out this
dreamlike realm once again links are
down below
and as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
you